I have begun taking my new supplements for the last cheek of swab. Unfortunately,
related or not, fluid started building up in my abdomen, which I had to have expelled
at the hospital. The doctor said the fluid was from the cancer. So yes, I would agree. So
the fluid is the, when you get a sighties in any cavity, whether it's in oral cavity or the abdominal
cavity, it's from a cancer. There's only theories on why that happens. There's no definitive answer
from why that happens. In addition, I could not urinate. My bladder was all so empty at the hospital.
I continue to have a hard time. You're at any of you. You don't have to go back to the hospital for
long-term stint. Is there anything I can do to help with urination? It's insured by having
it does not fill up and begin with fluid. There's nothing you can do to, you know, to ensure that
your abdomen will fill with fluid. I would say number one, do not wait until it gets bad. Get in there
more often than not. Because getting that drain, we've had people, you know, have, you know, get,
you know, five to seven liters drained off, you know, every three days. And you think, oh, is this
the end? No, they're still with us today. They recovered. So don't think that at all. But do not go,
well, I'm okay. I'll be fine. I'll just, you know, hold off for another week. Don't do that. Get in.
You're better off getting into the ER, getting that drain off more often than not.
More often than less often. So get in there as soon as you start to get some fluid accumulation.
Number two, if it's starting to block your urine flow, that gets dangerous because you'll get back
up into your kidney and you can get damaged to the kidneys. That's irreversible. So you do not want
to let that happen. If the urine blockage, and it sounds like the urine blockage is due to the fluid,
but in pressure on either the urethra or one of the ureters. And if that's the case,
then it's really removing the fluid to deal with the urination issue. If you have, if the, if the
inflammation is also caused, this is a male, I believe, that asks this question. So if the inflammation
also caused prosthetic, you know, you know, morbidity of a prosthetic hypertrophy at the same time,
then getting on some prostate nutrients can be helpful. But I don't know if I'm just guessing at that.
It sounds though that it is a physical pressure on the urethra or the ureter that's causing that.
Now you can help with that with it's a physical pressure by changing positions. The worst thing
you could do if it's a physical pressure putting the fluid just pressured the urethra is laid on your
back. So, you know, get down on all fours, like in a crawling position, like you're in a crawling,
just relax your tummy and try to just relax your abdominal muscles. So the fluid will settle
down, gravity will help pull it down towards the floor. That will help take some pressure,
can help take some pressure off the urethra. And see if they tell ways to see pregnant women
that that pressure and the baby can put pressure on your organs and doing that can help take
pressure off. That's one other thing you could do. Running some frequencies for bladder infections,
making sure you don't have a concurrent bladder infection can be beneficial. I don't know if in
the hospital they did a urine analysis, but you should ask for that next time you go in.
This is a routine UA to make sure there's not bacteria in your urine. That's present because you
could have a bladder infection as well and you want to address that. So make sure you don't
put food at it's, and you know, rough it out like a man, you've got to make sure you deal with that.